hey francis do you like books i tried
one once wasn't for me mike not enough
pictures of fit brand birds never
working with you again but if you like
fantasy check out the ripples in reality
series by j.s powell they're absolutely
brilliant and they have a five gold star
rating on amazon i've heard of them
they're beautifully written and
completely original if you want a book
that allows you to delve into different
worlds and helps you escape the insanity
of real life then ripples in reality is
for you
see i know the word death so i do read
books amazing just imagine books written
in the style of game of thrones lord of
the rings forgotten realms with an added
pinch of stargate it's catnip for people
like me virgins
she started a publishing company named
poppy field publishing and her novels
are a massive hit with fans who want to
read books that are a great read and are
not woke book one is shadow step
and book two gather shadows
she's currently writing book number
three i can't wait i don't read books
because i can talk to girls your mum
doesn't count mate and by the way js pal
is a big supporter of trigonometry she
is a moderator on our channel and we
really appreciate all her help you can
find her books online at amazonlulu.com
and other bookseller websites if you
enjoy the books please leave a review
the links are in the description
[Music]
hello and welcome to a very special live
episode of trigonometry i'm frances
foster i'm constantine kitchen and this
is a show for you if you want honest
conversations with fascinating people as
you know with the events in ukraine
there's been a lot of discussion and
debate about the history of that country
the history of the conflict and how we
are where we are and because of that
we're absolutely delighted to be joined
today by a british historian who's
written a number of books about that
part of the world about world war ii
including this book which i'm a huge fan
of the devil's alliance roger moorhouse
welcome to trigonometry but before we
welcome roger just to let you know that
it is a live episode and we will also be
doing uh super chats you get your chance
to ask questions to roger during the
break so it'll be 50 minutes we'll have
a quick break and then we'll be asking
your questions to roger so send us a
super chat if you want that apologies
wrong that's right welcome so good to
have you on the show i've been meaning
to get you on for a long time anyway but
the opportunity has now presented itself
before we get into the subject we're
going to be talking about tell everybody
a little bit about who you are how are
you where you are what has been your
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us uh a
twisted journey a little bit um yeah
uh author and historian um i studied in
the 90 early 90s at the school of
slavonic studies in london had a sort of
fascination with central european
history particularly which grew out of
89 which is
ironic really given what we're talking
about now because that's the sort of
start start point of where we're now
potentially at the end of that sort of
you know 30-year piece
um so i was fascinated by the events of
89 and that sort of inspired me to go to
university studied that and
all carried on from there ended up
researching with one of my professors
the great norman davies
and then started writing in my own right
as a freelance um
so i've written a few books now i do
also
lecture at uh as a visiting professor at
the college of europe in warsaw
and it's great to have you with us uh
you've uh you've written a bunch of
other books including your latest book
which is called uh first to fight which
is about the invasion of poland in 1939
uh and you've written quite a few books
about the cooperation between the soviet
union and and nazi germany at that time
which i i hear has has uh it doesn't
keep everybody happy particularly on the
eastern side of the world yeah yeah so i
mean particularly that one the devil's
alliance which is um the period of the
nazi soviet pact which is
um i think one of the most sort of
crucial events
in in world war ii actually and that
that german soviet relationship is one
of the most crucial great power
relationships of the war but it gets you
know routinely ignored in the western
narrative
um we treat the nazi soviet pact
essentially like it's the last sort of
chess move in the run-up to war
but it's actually the opening
uh salvo in a two-year relationship
between the two between moscow and
berlin which is very thorough going and
there's collaboration there's like four
economics treaties in that time
um they collaborate actively in the
destruction of poland uh in 1939 um so
there's it's a it's the forgotten great
power relationship and that's the story
i wanted to tell
which i think i did reasonably well very
well um there's
the russian narrative
currently which has hardened a lot under
putin in the last few years that came
out in
i think 2014. um
at the time and then since the russian
narrative on the nazi soviet pact has
hardened a lot and it's very uh
dismissive really of
that you know particularly my effort to
try and put it into a into a proper
context they still
very fixed on this sort of the the
immediate stalinist justification for it
which came after 41
which was just to say that this was you
know defensive necessity that we knew
hitler was going to attack us and we had
to do this it really isn't that simple
it's much more complex the reason i
bring it up is the elements of that
story that will become relevant when we
start talking about the history of
ukraine which is what i want to do now
so prior to the invasion as you know
vladimir putin made a speech in which he
essentially made three uh big claims
let's say the first of which was ukraine
was created by vladimir lenin and uh
allowed to be expanded by other
communist leaders like nikita khrushchev
and these are weak decisions made by
weak leaders that resulted in creation
of a fake country essentially that's the
first argument the second argument is
that this led to the splitting up of the
russian people the russian nation and a
piece of the russian nation was split
off and glued together with pieces of
poland and pieces of hungary where which
is where we're going to come on to the
the nazi soviet potentially and the
third argument is the eastward expansion
of nato since 1991
has
is a threat to russia uh russia is about
to be attacked by initially by ukraine
with western help and this is russia
defending itself by sending peacekeeping
forces into the donbass we've seen uh
how that has played out over the last
few days so let's stick to the history
first
what is the history of ukraine
did it exist was it artificially created
by vladimir lenin talk to us about that
yeah that's uh that's a whole crock of
nonsense i have to say for a start i
mean the idea that lenin sort of creates
ukraine
um what what
like all of these things there's always
a sort of a kernel of truth that they
then elaborate and run with you know at
the expense of everything else um and in
this case the sort of kernel of truth
here is that the early days of the
soviet union um of necessity this you
know soviet policy particularly under
lenin was very accommodating towards the
nationalities of the soviet union right
particularly in the caucasus where
you've got these sort of you know
fractious armenians and as areas of the
rest of it
um so but but elsewhere as well so it's
very very accommodating because central
power you know during the civil war was
so weak
um after 1918 onwards after the
revolution
um you essentially had to make those
concessions but they made it you know as
part of you know part of the sort of
almost the moral argument of communism
was that we're going to be nice to the
nationalities in the way that the
russian empire wasn't and a lot of
people bought into that
um very quickly at the end of the 1920s
once stalin's got back in or into power
after 28 onwards you know that this
tolerance of of uh minority ideas and so
on is completely crushed
um so anyone with sort of any ideas
about you know
not necessarily separatism but even uh
you know
a national policy in somewhere like
ukraine is is crushed and that you can
see that as one of the drivers behind
the terror famine in the holodomor of
the early 1930s part of that part of its
ideological and part of it is also an
effort to crush
ukrainian national ambition right
um so there's an element there where yes
they were you know encouraging of
national identity and national ideas in
places like ukraine after the revolution
but as a tactic um but ukrainian
identity and ukrainian
um
national identity goes way way back they
go right back to kievan rus which
actually predates moscow accidentally so
you know if you go right back to sort of
10th century kievan rus
um you know if putin wants to play you
know who's the senior partner games then
you know kiev wins hands down over
moscow so
it's an it's a nonsense to say that
ukraine has has no sort of history
beyond the 20th century it's a simple
nonsense
it seems to me and again correct me if
this is wrong
we don't understand
putin and his actions and his attitude
to ukraine because we don't understand
the culture we're not really taught
about the soviet union so his actions to
us seem completely bizarre
is that fair to say i think so i think i
think there's two things here i think
what
one aspect is and i saw rail about this
quite a lot i have done
almost into the void up until last week
um is that we in the last certainly 20
years since putin's been in power um and
i think during the period of the soviet
union before that
we in the west have fallen into the trap
of
treating
russia and before that the soviet union
um as if it's a normal state as if it's
a rational actor on the world stage
um
and they aren't and we're now seeing the
truth of that right it behaves like a
rogue state it behaves like an iran does
it's ideologically driven and it behaves
like iran would do in the same way so we
have to get our heads around the idea
that that putin now and russia's
behavior is that of a rogue state and
we're seeing that right that's now an
easier argument to make now than it was
ten days ago
um so that's one thing and then the
other the other point is and you you
touch on this francis that um
we don't know enough about soviet
history
in the west that i think is is
absolutely true there's been some shifts
but i think you know that policy
whenever it was it came in the 1990s
with the education reform where you've
got you know this foregrounding of of
german history nazi history with the
holocaust detached which is all well and
good but it leaves you know generations
certainly of british kids and others you
know beyond as well
with a sort of an imbalance in their
knowledge of 20th century
totalitarianism right so and i think you
can see that playing out with a lot of
the footage and stuff and a lot of this
memes on social media and so on and the
comparisons made
in opinion pieces in the last week that
sort of juxtapose putin's actions with
hitler's from 1938-39
and there's an argument to be made there
there are parallels it's quite a strong
one but you know putin is playing out
stalin's playbook as much as he's
playing out hitler's playbook i mean
it's a totalitarian playbook right and
if we knew more than just sort of you
know hitler and nazi germany
collectively then we could actually make
some meaningful comparisons and
meaningful comments but we're kind of
stuck in this world where the only point
of reference that we have historically
for the bad guy and the bad regime is
nazi germany and adolf hitler which is
kind of rather rather silly isn't it
because we also had to get into bed with
the soviets in world war ii in order to
win yeah that's part of it yeah so there
was this shift i mean it's interesting
that you know talk about the nazi soviet
pact
in that pit two-year period when they're
collaborating the west is pretty
clear-eyed about what's going on you
know churchill in particular yeah a
church and others but you know you can
look at you know editorials and
newspapers and you know across the west
world
talking about this
you know it's referred to in one in one
editorial as tutor slavia you know the
as nazi germany and the soviet union as
one entity all the way from um you know
the rhine effectively to to vladivostok
referring it to as one entity which you
know to a large extent it was they were
collaborating
um and then you do have that shift with
the grand alliance in 41 of necessity
right and that necessitated then a huge
kind of rehabilitation a huge propaganda
effort to rehabilitate stalin in the
eyes of the world you know he was no
longer the monster he was cuddly uncle
joe he sat on the sofa with church
and that that was kind of a necessity
but you know that essentially was what
stuck
i remember publicizing that book in you
know 2014 2015 and and i was doing a
public event and old chap stood up at
the end
um
and he was obviously the wartime
generation he stood up and and said
how dare you talk about stalling like
this so these these ideas are still out
there that stalin's somehow a good guy i
mean i find that absolutely astonishing
and it's particularly prevalent on the
left
who refused to condemn the soviet union
many times despite knowing that there
were atrocities happening yeah this is
one of those peculiarities particularly
the cold war that you know
that
sympathy for not you didn't even have to
be a card-carrying communist but just
sympathy on the left that
socialism in the communist sense was
seen as something that
yeah it might have you know it might
have broken a few skulls in ukraine it
might have you know made a few mistakes
but it was still something that was
worth defending
so you you kind of
caught yourself short of
criticizing even when it needed to be
criticized so that meant again that
imbalance is just perpetuated that you
get all of this sort of study on nazi
germany on the holocaust all of which is
right and proper but it's not balanced
out by by a concomitant study of you
know the holodomor for example you know
four million people died in the whole
automobile
well actually
there's some dispute about that even
even the russian state duma i think
recently acknowledged there were seven
million yeah i mean we that's i mean
that's part of the point we don't know
how many died it's huge
sort of
a central
guess figure is about four million which
is what i always give but you're right
it could be much higher well let's come
back to the present day because i think
that's what a lot of people watching
this and listening to this will care
about and rightly so of course
with what's happening in ukraine now one
of the things that
so the way i see the media landscape
shifting in the last few days even is
initially nobody knew what the hell was
going on so francis and i had a
conversation which i know you watched in
which i laid out some of my thoughts as
a sort of amateur historian who's a big
history buff and pays a lot of attention
to it and modern politics as well
but there is a competing argument
which i'd like us to talk about which
says that russia is not an aggressive
country under vladimir putin it was not
an aggressive country
until nato started expanding eastwards
and apparently some people argue the
verbal commitments were given to russia
uh to mikhail gombachev in particular
that russia would not expire that nato
would not expand eastwards
therefore sort of entering the strategic
area of interest for russia
and instead what happened was in 1999
poland which has a small border with
with russia and a couple of other
countries were allowed to join nato and
then in 2004 latvia estonia lithuania
countries that sit right on the border
of russia and form a corridor between
kaliningrad and russia very
strategically important for russia were
allowed to join
and
over time this was an irritant for
russia this is the equivalent of you
know mexico entering a defensive
alliance with the soviet union at the
peak of the cold war people argue
and as a result of that and further
encroachments and now ukraine sitting
right on the border part of the
historical russian sphere of influence
etc uh nato is planning to they've
they've said they would let ukraine and
georgia in that's when vladimir putin
went into georgia and now he's gone in
ukraine in 2014 when he could see
that you know these people don't the
people who say this don't understand the
history of modern ukraine this was not a
neutral government this was a russian
puppet who was about to be replaced with
someone who was pro-western and so when
vladimir putin saw this he saw a country
on the border about to join nato he went
in and he tried to wreck the country to
prevent him from being a bull walk
against russia for nato what say to that
i think the key phrase in all of that
need i mean there was a lot packaged in
that constantine but the key phrase in
there was the idea of a russian sphere
of influence
which is kind of a um an item of faith
in the kremlin still
um and and it isn't for the rest of the
world effectively and certainly for the
world that we're talking about baltic
states poland and now ukraine as well
um
and this is where i think we come back
to that's a wider issue of where we are
uh in a sort of geopolitical sense we've
had
a 30-year piece effectively from the
cold war we've we in the west you know
arrogantly naively whatever we thought
the cold war was over in 1989 91 soviet
union collapsed
um
places like
poland finally become independent so you
know 40 odd years after the end of the
world end of world war ii when
uh
us british and the french went to war to
you know supposedly defend polish
independence and integrity that
isn't actually restored until 1989
tragically but again 91 baltic states
re-emerges independent states and have
flourished done brilliantly so you know
from the western perspective this is all
good right
um russia's independence russia is under
this strong man but you know someone we
can supposedly do business with we
thought
ukraine is somewhere in between
independent states
and and we see that world as a positive
development these are free countries
that are you know forwarding their way
making sovereign decisions whether they
join the eu like the baltic states did
or joined nato like again like the bulk
states did and poland
um
that to us is all is all fine and normal
this is how normal states
behave right
from a
kremlin perspective they're still
thinking in terms of
a russian sphere of influence that has
been
undermined that has been damaged by that
process
so with the collapse of the soviet union
obviously you know they in 1989 they
lose that effect of control over eastern
europe which they had through communism
through those satellite communist
regimes and then the soviet union itself
collapses
um for them that is
that putin said this i think in about
2000 or just before he said the collapse
of the soviet union was the greatest
geopolitical uh catastrophe that was
that happened in 20th century which is
saying something right began world war
ii yeah that's that's that is putin's
mindset the collapse of the soviet union
is the greatest
geopolitical catastrophe of his time
which is astonishing and why would he
say that because it is russia losing
that position of influence that sphere
of influence you know
russian power russia as a as a great
power um whether it's riding on the
coattails of the soviet union that was
effectively russia writ large right
effectively um but now russia is an
independent state it you know it's not
enough for the kremlin to be within just
the borders of russia as it is that's
that's that's not acceptable why not
roger why not don't we live in this
wonderful world of peace and trade and
we can all just exist within the borders
that we have and just be you know
unicorns and rainbows and all that well
yeah we thought so exactly we thought
that was the world we lived in and it's
not a it's not a ridiculous assumption
really
um it's a question of you know
perspective for the western world it's
about you know sovereign nations and
trading and all of that which is all you
know that's that's the world we live in
and we're quite happy with that but you
have to understand that from a soviet
person from a russian perspective
freudian slip there but from a russian
perspective that's completely anathema
that's not the way the world works the
world works in terms of
spheres of influence and particularly
you know the example of ukraine is
absolutely salient here right you can
kind of justify
letting go of baltic states right
because
all right they've got russian minorities
but they're lithuanians they're bolts
they're you know they're latvians
estonians you know they were never
really with us from a from a kremlin
perspective
um and letting them go was probably you
know easier than trying to keep hold of
them in 1991.
um but letting ukraine go
is unthinkable and it goes back to what
you said earlier on about this idea of
you know russian nationalism isn't just
russia in its
you know modern boundaries
it it implies a
sort of claim to ukraine it has this
sort of greater russian idea to ukraine
and also to belarus
so to let one of those two go
is absolutely not acceptable from a
kremlin perspective
um and
this is where you know belarus the
problem with belarus from again from a
kremlin perspective has kind of been
solved right he had that
um the election of last year lukashenko
is still there you know defying
a lost election um he's clamped down
thrown out those that you know
legitimately should be the government
um looks guy has done a brilliant job of
going around the world and getting
handshakes and photo ops with with the
rest of the world
i fear that's probably game over for
belarus for the foreseeable
um so that from a criminal perspective
is belarus problem solved but ukraine
was edging towards some sort of you know
looking westward increasingly democratic
reasonably successful functioning
these are all things that the kremlin
can't afford wasn't 2014 a coup
supported by the cia i hear
i think i mean this is just this is just
it there's that great uh line um kremlin
101 or dictator 101 is is kind of accuse
your enemy of what you're doing right
um and that's a great example of this
you know i i
i don't see
um
west the idea of western meddling it
just doesn't really happen we don't have
we we don't have the sort of the the
brain power and the will
we just don't
i mean it's it's it's it's rather
ridiculous and i think you know that
that is a great example nato of course
is a defensive alliance you know
uh
the kremlin at the moment is doing a
great job of advertising for nato
right you can see the finns and the
swedes are now thinking about they're
also being berated by by uh putin and
saying you know you if you watch it if
you apply there'll be trouble
but they probably will and why wouldn't
they given the current situation
so if you offered a nato membership to
ukraine now they'd have your arm off
yeah you know so he's the greatest
recruiting sergeant for nato membership
that you could imagine so it's it's a
response to him it's not you know he's
not responding to any sort of
provocation
nato is a response to russia i'm gonna
make what could be seen as a cross
illusion but i think it's got merit it
sounds like russia is having a sort of
weird mid-life crisis where they're
looking back at their you know are they
at their youth or their earlier times
going this is great those were the days
yeah those were the days this was great
basketball racist
russophobic mate yeah and they were
looking back at the days in the halcyon
days of the soviet union where they were
great and powerful they
they're looking at their place in the
world they're feeling diminished
and they want to impose themselves once
again despite the fact
that the world's moved on i think
there's a lot of that um and you can see
you know to to coin a phrase you know
putin is is wanting to make russia great
again that's
that's that's where he's heading you can
see the same thing
um historically you can see the same
drivers in nazi germany you know because
that was a great power
humiliated at the end of the first world
war um
populations outside of its of its
redrawn frontiers taken away from it
taken away you know um
national humiliation and then you've got
the great leader who comes in and
restores you know germans faith in
themselves and restores its position in
the world
um and then starts going after these
iridenta and these disputed territories
so there's there's definite sort of
parallels there
um
which is kind of you know from our
perspective now
as of last week profoundly worrying i'm
not i'm not going to go down the route
of saying this is world war three but
this is certainly i think cold war ii
well 100
so the one thing that i think
differentiates hitler from from i nearly
said stalin from putin
is he doesn't seem to have a racial
animus yeah
not in that conventional not in the sort
of conventional you know rabid sense
that hitler did
um i think putin has
i mean i i
in terms of ideology i would have said i
think up until probably a couple of
weeks ago i would have said that putin
is kind of
doesn't really have an ideological angle
um apart from this sort of um you know
robber capitalism kleptocracy that he
runs um and
a an aggravated sense of of russian
nationalism right
um
but then that
what happened last week kind of i think
throws that idea that he's a rational
actor out of the window because that is
not that's not the behavioral behavior
of a rational politician
now he was getting what he wanted
while saber-rattling against ukraine but
you know he was getting the western
politicians flying to moscow and
elsewhere you know and talking about
redrawing the sort of security structure
in in europe and he was already
strangling ukraine
just by making sure that western western
companies were leaving or they weren't
going and investing there he was already
doing what he wanted to do which is
making sure that he had ukraine
essentially by the balls and it wasn't
going to go anywhere
so which is why up until 30 last week
like many others i thought he'd be mad
to invade he's not going to invade it
would be ridiculous and then of course
innates so
this is where we have to start thinking
that actually there are some ideological
drivers behind this
that
um we collectively weren't really seeing
and this is why i think that you know
there's an element here where some of
those thinkers
around the kremlin
um
are pretty close to what you could call
kind of russian fascism
and this is where it gets much much
darker
and yeah it doesn't have necessarily
that racial element but it is certainly
a sort of a greater russian ambition not
uniting all the russian people in one
state that sort of thing
um which is you know
is is sort of
essentially one of the sort of ambitions
of classical fascism you know is
ethno-nationalism so you're on the same
path there
the thing that's worrying what you say
about that you think
well then is another world war
inevitable because if he's going to
carry on encroaching
once he's locked down ukraine he'll
probably think that is then going to be
right i've got what i want from here but
actually
those countries over there they were
once part of the soviet union they
should be part of russia
let's go well this is um
i would preface anything i say by again
reiterating that i didn't think he'd
invade last week so any of my
predictions i did let me answer that
question
my gut feeling on this is that you know
as i've just said there's this strong
element of russian ethnic nationalism
which from a um you can see from putin's
speech last week
very strongly includes ukrainians and
belarusians in that in that sphere right
that's the world he's looking to reunite
um
by definition really that means you
don't want the baltic states you don't
want to go into poland and so on plus
baltic states poland they're all nato
members so that would be a
direct
slap in the face for nato nato would be
obliged to respond
um so that would be
a massive
massive step further so
i can see you know as i said that the
russian problem is or belarus problem
has kind of been
solved from a kremlin perspective
and he's in the process
of very bloodily and brutally solving
the ukrainian problem that was even the
phrase that was used in
or a speech from last week
um
which is rather
clumsy
formulation historically speaking
solving the uh
ukrainian problem
um so
to my mind i think that that that would
be job done but it does mean from
western perspective it means effectively
that you know ukraine is lost which is
which is a tragedy
um because
that
we need to collectively stand up and
uh i think defend that freedom which
i've been amazed at what the west has
done in the last week i think i've been
astonished me too actually uh
how much more we can do i don't know
that's a question for the for the
strategists and the field marshals roger
let's come back to the history a little
bit because we talked about the
comparison with hitler's expansion
following the humiliation of germany and
this is what i think a lot of
sort of 22 year olds on twitter who are
now experts on geopolitics
don't seem to
understand is that i would argue and i'm
i i've got to be very careful about the
way i phrase this so i'm going to
preface this by using a bit of identity
politics by saying that my
great-grandfather died fighting nazis
probably died in the holocaust jewish
blah blah blah blah blah
but hitler had quite legitimate reasons
from his perspective to demand the
sudetenland
to demand the angelus to demand all of
that like there were germans in the
sudetenland and they were being badly
treated right
yeah um
the reason i bring it up is what i'm
trying to get at is like
people like putin and who others they
will make claims that have a kernel of
truth it does not mean that the claim is
true yeah i think i think you can
actually draw a very close comparison
between the dayton land issue in 1938
yeah and
donnie x in new hampshire quite now
right
or
prior to last week um to a large extent
they're manufactured crises that you
then are obliged to find a solution for
um the sudanese land uh problem as it
were was um you know ethnic germans
within that sort of fringe of bohemian
moravia which is now czech republic um
that bordered on to germany but actually
they're all of their
cultural references they spoke german or
rest of the course but all of their
cultural references of the sudeten
germans went southwards went towards
austria so they a lot of them didn't
feel themselves to be germans they felt
themselves still to be austrians because
that was
you know where they'd been marooned from
in 1918 at the end of the first world
war
um so there's there was a lot of
diversity of opinion yes they spoke
german this is this is like
dominion in la hands right yes they
spoke german it didn't necessarily mean
they wanted to go and join berlin
because they they saw that as you know
that was protestant country those were
the the prussians as they used to call
them we they were all sort of uh
catholic and they were very south german
more in common with austria more coming
with pokemon with bavaria so there are
sort of profound differences
um and what you have is
yes you know they're not well treated
within within uh pre-war check slovakia
um but you've got the sort of creation
of a problem that that that styling the
earth started hitler then um goes in and
solves with the with the annexation um
so
it's very analogous to donetsk and
lehanska at the moment um or up until
last week
and what do you make of the the the sort
of commensurate claims that russia is
making that uh there's a genocide
happening in the donbass uh i mean i
find it difficult to entertain this
conversation because i have family and
friends who live there who talk about it
like but but you are here to give an
objective opinion about it so what do
you make of the claims that there's been
a genocide thousands of ethnic russians
are being annihilated every day and yeah
i mean as far as i can tell there's been
there's absolutely no proof of that
right i mean i haven't seen any proof
anywhere uh serious proof um the problem
you have with this is that you know you
look back again to the sort of um
the halcyon days of the european
dictators in the 1930s and 40s they're
constantly inventing
problems like these that then require a
solution
um so
and again sort of false flag operations
which we saw last week as well you know
that ridiculous false flag again i think
it was in donetsk god bless wasn't it
there was um you know some burnt out
truck with a body in it but you know
the skull of which had patently been
used for had already been autopsied and
they were saying this was a result of
ukrainian violence against russians i
mean
it's the clumsiest sort of false flag
you could possibly imagine
or you know supposed provocation this is
what these regimes do it's part of the
playbook and this is why actually you
know i'm always wary of this idea of um
you know history as a sort of a
a teacher in a way you know because
we're constantly
i think to some extent abusing history
in the western world but this is a good
example where a good knowledge of that
period and how these regimes functioned
as a matter of course you look at the
glivitz incident in 1939 1939 right now
the run-up to the night before the
german invasion you look at them
hold on sorry i'm so sorry
no one knows in the west in my
experience because i tried to talk to
people about the sick lives incidentally
about blood so so most people in the
west think that world war ii started
when germany invaded poland
what they don't know is world what you
started if the nazis had won the history
books would read when poland invaded
germany tell us about that yeah the
night before so that the um the german
invasion the poem of course is dawn on
the 1st of september the night before
31st of august um there is a
raid on a german radio station in the
town of gleivitz which was about five
kilometers from the polish border it was
in germany
five kilometers from the polish border
it's now glivitzer in southwestern
poland
um
and
group about eight men in civil so not in
military uniform burst into this radio
station fire a couple of shots into the
air
um tie up the station personnel who are
germans of course put them in the cellar
and then start to try and broadcast an
incendiary mesh message in polish one of
them spoke spoke polish
which basically said you know um we're
the advanced guard we're waiting for the
uh for polish forces and we're advancing
on berlin and you know down with hitler
and down with nazism
um of course they're all ss men right um
they they don't actually manage to to
broadcast their message they [ __ ] it up
you get a lot of white noise apparently
apparently there was nine seconds of the
message was heard and then after that it
was white noise nobody knows why
um anyway they don't know that they
think they've done their job they leave
the site and they leave one guy
and a rather unfortunate pole who had
been a polish agitator in german episode
easier called franchise honyak
and he's left behind and shot he'd
already been drugged and he's left shot
and left behind as
you know
bloody proof that this was a polish
operation right
um and then of course the following day
if you jump forward to nine o'clock the
following day hitler makes a speech
in front of the reichstag german
parliament
um in berlin where he says you know we
are fighting back since 545. so he's
weaponizing that
that spurious false flag operation from
the previous night this was it was an
idea that came from himmler and heydrich
apparently
soviet union did the same in finland
soviet union did the same in finland i
was going to say so the mynila incident
finland 30th of november 1939
the red army shells its own border post
kills about you know three or four red
army men um shells its own border post
and then blames the finns and then
invades finland in response i mean this
is how totalitarian's powers uh behave
and i think
what's fascinating is that back in the
day in 39 and beyond you know i mean
gulf of tonkin is another one in the
1960s not just totalitarians do this um
but
back in the day
because of how broadcasting worked and
how information gathering works and the
rest of it you know
what the outside world didn't know the
truth right so you kind of left with
just accepting
or not the the official account right
but now with you know social media and
rest of it which is a very very
democratic form of communication it's
very very bottom-up
you know you can have people on the
ground like that example last week that
i that i mentioned you can have people
on the ground filming and going this
doesn't look like an ordinary corpse
this is actually this has already been
autopsied what's it doing here and
immediately the narrative kind of
it's is destroyed right so
that might have worked that might still
work for domestic russian consumption
if they showed that on on russian tv
and said you know this is proof that
these ukrainians are doing dastardly
things then maybe that works in russia
it just doesn't work for the outside
world anymore
that's the difference
and the worrying thing is
is that we talk about hitler and we're
making these comparisons and the more
comparisons
there are and the more specific
comparisons there are the more worried
and anxious i become
and then you think to yourself that on
top of that
russia's got isn't it the highest amount
of nuclear weapons or the second highest
amount compared to the united states
at least hitler didn't have nukes yeah
true um that is the sort of great sort
of specter hanging over all of this and
i mean this idea
um if we accept as i kind of described
earlier on if we accept that
putin is motivated
more by ideology than we've
traditionally thought like as i said we
just thought he was a russian
nationalist and a kleptocrat right
but if there's more going on than that
um
more ideological kind of background if
you like then i don't know if that makes
uh the prospect of
uh
you know him pressing the button more or
less uh possible
it's certainly worrying um i'd still you
know cling to the hope that he's not
that mad and his ideology isn't that
ridiculous that it would that it would
drive him to that but
as i said i didn't think he would invade
ukraine in first place well let me let
me make francis slightly more depressed
than he already is by saying i've spent
the last few days
uh i'm grateful to be able to speak
russian to understand that the country
having lived there and being from there
etc watching russian television
uh state television and for people who
are listening to us they should
understand russia isn't like britain or
america in the
like we think everyone in britain's on
twitter they're not but in russia the
overwhelming majority of people get
their news from mainstream television in
a way that people in this country no
longer do
i've been shocked by how religious it is
religion never used to get talked about
and kutan mentioned the religious split
in the ukrainian and russian churches in
his speech there is a very clear
signaling that there's a religious
element to all of this and that worries
me tremendously i have to say because
you know it becomes like a crusade right
and if you're going to press a button to
kill to kill everyone in the world
there's this we know that ideologically
speaking there's a very good way of you
know doing that
but let's come back to a bit more sort
of
historical conversation i'm putting
arguments to you that i see people out
there putting which just boggles my mind
so ukraine is a country that in uh
elected
uh vladimir lenski
who's a jewish comedian president
and
it's full of nazis apparently roger
yeah again everyone's a nazi now look
there's some things we should address
because
in western ukraine there is a history of
fascism
and there were some people who
collaborated with the germans and not
only for pure convenience they
collaborated with the germans because
they were fascists they they believed in
it that was their ideology stephan
bandera undoubtedly fascists there's no
question and there's some people in
ukraine who want to deny that and some
mistakes have been made about sort of
trying to clean up his past which i i
think was a mistake and there's a
battalion there's of battalion which is
full of neo-nazis in ukraine so how do
we square all of that how do we square
that circle yeah i think that i mean
that
to to some extent that sort of you know
the um privacy sector and
as of battalion and so on
um
i think to some extent that tends to
happen
um when you have a state you know being
invaded by its neighbor it's kind of
almost a you know it's a natural
reaction we would have probably
if we were invaded by scotland we'd have
a battalion of edl boys up there you
know doing the same thing and waving
flags and saying unacceptable things
so it's to some extent that again it's a
reaction to circumstances and again i
mean
every country has that in it
it's part of the spectrum of politics we
cannot like it but it's there right it
doesn't mean that the entire country is
is run by and and you know dominated by
nazis it's a ridiculous extrapolation so
i think you know in the modern sense i
think you know yes it's there but you
know to say that that's
how it how the country is run and that's
who zalenski is is nonsense
um historically it's i mean is is more
complicated and you mentioned bandera
we have to bear in mind i agree with
what you say actually about bandera and
and the the way
ukraine
in
groping its way towards the symbols of
nationalism and creating its nation and
its national myth and so on which every
every nation has to do you know you have
to sort of find your heroes and so on
and you have to create a usable myth of
your of your existence which actually
incidentally what's going on now
brutal and bloody and murderous though
is is a brilliant foundation myth for a
future ukraine yeah you know and there
will be statues of zolensky in a future
ukraine without question
um so this is a little bit to my mind
the echo here is a little bit of
the warsaw rising in 1944 which
i'm not i don't want to
damn and sort of prejudge what's going
on in ukraine but was ultimately doomed
but as a a brilliant kind of uprising
against german rule and incidentally
against the
possibility of russian rule soviet rule
um but was doomed and was betrayed and
you know
hundreds of thousands killed
um but as a sort of foundation myth for
the democratic polling that emerges in
89 you know it's tremendously powerful
and i think you you're kind of seeing an
analogous situation here as well i mean
hopefully it's not going to be another
40 years
but you're seeing an analogous situation
so every country needs to find its you
know usable history and i think that's
reaching for bandera is
profoundly questionable yeah i think
wrong-headed yeah right
um same with banning the russian not
banning but not using russian language
and official documents yeah that doesn't
help
there's no question that in the desire
to build the nation they've been
mistaken absolutely no question about
that yeah and that that's not the same
as what people are saying so i'm a
russian speaker i don't speak a word of
ukrainian my wife is a she speaks
ukrainian but she's a russian-speaking
ukrainian most of my family are
russian-speaking ukrainians some
pro-russian by the way some
pro-ukrainian not a single person would
claim to have ever been discriminated
against for being a russian speaker of
russian ethnicity in ukraine that's
that's just a lie now mistakes have been
made i agree and glorifying people like
stephan bandera was a mistake yeah i
think
i'm not to defend bandera but i think as
well we have to again
there's a common problem is to look back
at the sort of maelstrom
of central europe
in 1942-43
right the height of the holocaust the
height of you know various central
europe is a mess in that period you know
they're sort of pockets of of polish
occupation or polish populations still
they're you know in in a ukrainian sea
and vice versa it's all mixed up and
then jewish populations all over that
are being slaughtered right
um and bandera effectively hitches his
wagon to the germans because he thinks
he might be able to create some sort of
ukrainian
statelet out of it he might be able to
you know ride the nazi tiger to some
form of ukrainian statehood right
and he misjudges it right but um roger
he ends up in sacks and houses he does
but i'm sorry to interrupt but i just
wanted everyone to be clear about this
he was a fascist yeah it's not that he
saw an opportunity and so he went oh
let's just join these guys i know
they're bad but it's okay no no he was a
fascist yeah he he he wanted the same
thing in ukraine that they were doing in
germany yeah and he wanted to eliminate
the jews he wanted to eliminate the
polls right that was the ideologies is
not a good person no no absolutely
making an international hero i think
there's a there's a peril in here i
agree with all of that constantly but
there's a peril here of looking back and
judging people in 4243 in in that
absolute male strum of war in central
europe which is unbelievably brutal yeah
uh and judging them by mod sort of
comfortable i'm not judging him i'm
judging the people who've tried to make
him into a national hero since yeah i
agree okay
i was gonna say the thing that i find
because obviously
with your history
and your knowledge of the region i'm
looking at this very much through
through the eyes of a complete layman
the thing that i find worrying is that
you're making parallels again and again
with world war ii the beginning of the
world war
and for somebody who doesn't know a lot
about world war ii history
a lot of it is to do i think with
complacency complacency with people like
chamberlain who don't realize
the rising threat of nazi germany who
don't understand what they're dealing
with with adolf hitler and the nazi
party
are the same mistakes being made again
with putin in his party and russia in
general i think we have been
remarkably complacent in dealing with uh
putin and russia um
particularly since
uh the turn of about 10 years ago um i
mean the
invasion of georgia was 2008.
we should really have seen the writing
on the walls then
um
prior to that maybe it's acceptable that
you could you could have said you know
putin's a tough guy but he's okay and
you know he's for stability and the rest
of it i mean he comes to power into 2000
kind of promising russians you know
stability and prosper proster prosperity
and all the all the western things that
that they wanted right and look where
he's taking them 22 years later
but we should have seen the writing on
the walls certainly 2008 if failing that
um
with the um
euromaidan in 2013-14
we just been too slow we've been too
slow in actually recognizing that threat
there's been enough voices
um i mean i'm a small voice but i've
i've been sort of consistently critical
and it comes through in my books as well
you know i do see
i do see the soviet union
and by extension russia as a sort of
malevolent player in the region
um
and that's sort of fed by the history
and it's just plain to see and once
you've seen it it's one of those things
you can you can't unsee
um
there have been a few
you know
statesmen of that of that um region
there have been a few um journalists
that specialize in that in that sort of
um
region people like edward lucas has been
brilliant on this and consistent on this
all the way through so there have been
voices but they just tend to get
dismissed and people say well you're
just being russophobic
you know we can do business it's the you
know the germans with their wonderful
phrase they had this wonderful phrase up
until last week
of vandal handle which means change
through trade
right so we'll trade with the we'll do
trade with with the russians and but in
that way by showing them the benefits
of being part of the club we will change
them for the better right
that has crashed and burned as of last
thursday
but isn't it all so francis before you
jump in i'm really sorry just remind the
guys everybody if you want to ask
questions of roger or of us send in the
super chat send in the paypal our team
will collate them and after we have a
break in a few minutes we'll come back
and answer all those questions sorry
enough no it's cool
we're sitting here in london
let's be honest
a lot of people in london have got very
rich
very fat
of russian money a lot of it incredibly
incredibly dodgy wasn't it as well
it wasn't in a lot of people's best
interests there are a lot of politicians
to criticize putin to criticize russia
when we had all that money being
funneled into the city of london
yeah i think i think there's a danger
here of kind of
seeing patterns that are weren't
necessarily apparent yeah um
in retrospect i mean some people were
saying that as i mentioned that lucas he
was saying that all the way through
uh it's been consistent but um
you know it's all very well in
retrospect to sort of pull these things
up um hold on roger come on this guy has
poisoned people on the street absolutely
the streets of the country he's killing
off his political opponents he's exiled
anyone like these are just i'm putting
the counter argument right he's he's
destroyed any sort of democratic
opposition in russia whatsoever he shut
down every satirical program that they
exist he's now shut down every
independent media channel in russia as
well like
now here's the question really is could
we have done anything that's a different
conversation right because can you do
some of the things that we're now doing
because he poisoned one guy
in salisbury i think i think that should
have been a shift i think salisbury
should have been shifted that we that we
actually you know put into put into
place meaningful sanctions at that point
which i don't think we do over one guy
this is the paralysis of the west well
it is but it's also you know that using
chemical weapons effectively you know on
foreign soil is is is
astonishing
astonishing thing to have done
and that i you know that it was good to
see at the time you know remember
theresa may being very firm in the house
of commons but i don't remember what
followed on from that i don't think
there was much in the way of real
sanctions and by way of punishment so
there's a lot of words not much action
um so that i think should have been a
turning point but but to address the you
know the previous point about that sort
of infiltration of russian money uh of
of influence all of that i think that's
something that um we have to be careful
now that we don't sort of throw out the
baby with the bath water because what
the west model is built on is you know
rule of law and and property rights and
all that sort of thing so in this sort
of rush to punish you know um russian
oligarchs and the rest of it which i'm
fully on board with we still have to
make sure that we go down the right
right routes and the right processes and
it's and it's above board because you
know if we end up behaving like
uh you know a russian autocrat and just
throwing people out and doing things
extra legally then we know better than
they are so i think we do have to make
sure that our response is is legal
anything that screws over chelsea
football club mate is going to be good
it's a good thing well on that happy
note roger we're going to get some
questions from our audience and we've
got a bunch of other things that we want
to ask you as well but we're going to go
to a quick break and we're back in a
couple of minutes guys send in your
super chat send in your paypal and i
will get your questions out to roger see
you in a couple of minutes
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike i already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
who a
biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is libya
tech is the library you idiot exactly
you can never be too far away from
knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babble's 15-minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real-world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people so
you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones
babble is available as an app or online
and your progress will be synced across
all devices babel is offering our
listeners six months free with the
purchase of a six month subscription
with our promo code which is trigger go
to babble.com forward slash play and use
promo code trigger for an extra six
months for free we're even gonna get
francis on it you might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now yo
absolutely perfecto know what i mean
gary
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns of
rock solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com forward
slash triggered and use our promo code
which is of course triggered as well and
you will get 50 off with the initial
purchase sign up for their newsletter
access of easy that tells you everything
you need to know about technology
privacy and censorship
hello welcome back everybody we're going
to ask some questions of roger and have
another conversation which has been
absolutely brilliant so far uh france is
far away the first question is we've got
one from regular icky ike and he says
i'm sure putin doesn't believe his own
propaganda but if you're swimming in
misinformation can't it corrupt your
perception of reality could putin
absorbing a bit too much of the kremlin
kool-aid have led to his overreach
i think that's a pretty fair assumption
yeah and you can see that from
uh
a lot of that sort of footage of the
last few weeks of
the sort of theater within the kremlin
of how he is presented and how he's
presented with other people that
ridiculously long table for example and
then sitting there in the in the hall
you know distanced from his um from his
oligarchs and his ministers and so on
um and this
coveted
paranoia that he evidently has as well
that everyone has to you know provide
stool samples and you know two weeks of
isolation or whatever it is i mean it's
insane but i think that there's an
element of that where he has
whether it's just psychological or it's
also it's also covid related that he's
effectively isolated himself and he
isolated in that
rather delusional world so i think
there's that's quite a strong case for
that being correct yeah and if that is
the case then surely
doesn't that make him even more
dangerous yes
because it makes him the chances are
that if he's isolated he becomes ever
more irrational he becomes ever more
erratic and therefore more likely to do
something stupid
yes
right certainly francis but i don't know
i agree absolutely you're doing to him
what i did
you just i saw that and you you
depressed him and i mean i i agree i
watched that and i agreed with an awful
lot of what you said uh steve asked what
i think is actually a very fair question
he says of putin's three justification
justifications that he gave nato i mean
he doesn't mention that the fact that
ukraine belongs according to putin to
that part belongs to russia but he says
nato nazis and kosovo we haven't
addressed the kosovo precedent can you
talk about that because that's not
something i know a lot about
and i'd love to understand some people
are arguing that what happened with
kosovo being split off was a precedent
for
what putin is doing and he went well if
you're doing this then i'm going to do
this can you yeah and he talked he talks
as well about you know the bomb tell us
what happened to kosovo as well yeah oh
uh
because right no one knows yeah well i'm
not sure i know
and that's going back to you know the
end of the yugoslav wars um that was
there was the nato first of all no fly
zone and then the bombing of belgrade
um which
was deemed necessary at the time um
there were obviously voices of descent
and then the same thing with with the
creation of kosovo um
which
to a serbian mind kosovo incidentally
has a sort of
almost
mythological element it's a mythological
territory for serbians right for serbs
so
um you can see there that that is
something that is still as a running saw
for for serbians that certainly
nationalist sensibilities
and there's a close affinity between the
serbs and the russians as you know pan
slavs and all of that and historically
there's there's always been close ties
serbia was one of those that actually
came out last week and didn't support
sanctions against russia so you know you
can see those those those links are
still there
um
but
you know if we accept that that that's
an example of sort of nato
overreach it's where nato
cease to become
in one example it
ceases to become that purely defensive
alliance i was talking about it actually
was offensive in that case
um
then you know we can look back and say
yes you know mayor cooper so maybe that
was the wrong thing to have done but we
were trying to you know humanitarian
mission trying to
essentially finish a civil war
um so that
i think you know
is something we can argue out in the
west
with sort of free discussion of of
events but for them for the russians to
use that as justification you know our
error is allowing them to do what
they're doing the same thing as using
using the the um
um
uh invasion of iraq for example and say
well you invaded iraq well that's the
most ridiculous excuse in the world why
is that right because iraq was an
absolute [ __ ] show so why would anyone
want to use that as a sort of you know
as an excuse to do the same thing and
it's this preposterous yeah you know it
was a it was a mistake absolutely but
why would you want to then go and do a
mistake and claim that that's your
justification for doing it mm-hmm right
common sense this is something we
haven't covered and we haven't talked
about the west's role beyond the nato
conversation i want to talk to you about
this because as you know in that
conversation francis and i had i was
putting very strongly the case that the
west has undermined its moral authority
yeah there's no question about that
right yes and so even in the eyes of our
fellow citizens
of russia in the situation can sound a
bit hollow
because of the immoral
illegal
you know improper whatever word you want
to use actions that we take time and
time again in the last 20 30 40 50 70
200 500 years
number one number two
the other thing about the west which as
you know
i think we all feel strongly about is
the constant undermining of the values
of our civilization from the inside
and therefore withdrawing from the world
and so we sort of hint to ukraine that
it can come and join the family of
western nations but we don't do it
properly we just hint we say well yeah
you're welcome but we're not actually
gonna help you make that a reality
what is the west role in your opinion
and what mistakes do you think we have
made
that have caused this to happen or have
contributed to what's happening now yeah
i mean i think
absolutely we make mistakes you know
that's every every nation every every
political entity makes mistakes
the great thing about the western model
is that
we can recognize them we can discuss
them freely
we can
where necessary vote out those
responsible we can prosecute those
responsible but we don't do it we don't
we don't take you know tony blair to the
hague but um you know we can vote him
out of office for example you know so
nothing's perfect but you know which
system do you want to live under you
know do you want to live under putin's
system this is this it kind of annoys me
this
knee-jerk thing that you see a lot at
the moment and there was great peace
douglas murray did a great piece today i
think in spectator
very good piece what the right gets
wrong yeah talking about you know the
american right kind of swooning for
putin i think
what are you wishing for yourselves here
this is ridiculous i mean however much
you find you know the modern uh western
world with all of its woke you know
nonsense in many cases
however frustrating you find that
a viable alternative is not supporting
an autocratic
the fact that you don't like that and he
doesn't like that stuff yeah doesn't
make you allies no right he would have
you shot yeah right we have to
understand that and i think
he's quite good on the trans debate
though yeah he is he's very red-pilled
and based but but but this on that point
though and this and i think we've seen
this in the last week this has been
i think a very valid and valuable
wake-up call yes for the western world
yes to actually look at stop looking at
our navels and start stop talking about
you know
for once microaggressions and and and
you know transgender toilets or whatever
it is and actually look at what values
we hold in common and are they worth
defending and the rest of the world has
stood up in the last week last year last
week rather and said yes they are worth
defending you know those basic freedoms
democracy you know
freedom all rule of law all of that
stuff is worth defending my big concern
with what i'm observing in the last week
is that look the anti-anti-imperialist
anti-war anti-establishment left
has always been very open about hating
the west hating the western values
cozying up to dictators whether it be in
the soviet union and venezuela or
whatever because ideologically they're
motivated by the belief that the west is
evil
what it does around the world is evil
and any evil that happens around the
world is inevitably a consequence of
western evil yeah so when venezuela goes
down the toilet that's not because of
what sanctions
it's sanctions it's all of that right so
and look people it's a free country you
believe whatever you want and those
people some of them are great people
there some of them are smart some of
them i don't agree with them i think
they're badly wrong but that's what they
think
what hadn't occurred to me and what i
think we're starting to see now on some
parts of the right
is they hate
the west too now because of all this
work all that stuff and so they they
will side with anybody
who just says yeah men and women women
are women that to me is a pretty [ __ ]
low bar roger for supporting somebody i
agree i agree women are women and men
are men but we've got to we've got to
reach further we've got to have a bit
more ambition and a bit more aspiration
about who we want to be representing our
values and if you know this is the point
i've been making for years now i'm sorry
that i'm ranting but i feel strongly
about this is like you know we talk so
much about racism and sexism and
homophobia in this country well
you want to go and look at russia what
happens to gay people there or china or
whatever like these countries are not
better
they're not better and i'd say that to
you if you're woke or if you're
anti-work
you've got to remember that you know
this you don't want to throw away the
baby with the bathroom absolutely and i
think we're really really in danger of
doing that particularly people who you
know i feel that i felt well francis and
i were having a very honest conversation
about this last night
you know
i think lockdown broke a lot of people's
brains mine included i found it very
difficult to to just hold myself
from going over into sort of conspiracy
and madness because what was happening
around us
made so little sense
that you could i think everyone felt a
desire to kind of reach for an
explanation and if what's happening in
front of you is so ridiculous
it's natural then to seek ridiculous
explanations for what's happening and
that is a big concern for me in terms of
the ideological space that we're now in
i agree with all of that concentrate the
only thing i'd say again is that in the
last week
the way the west has responded yes is
has been hugely heartening yes you know
for me as well we we have you know
rediscovered the wood for the trees we
we now know what we stand for you know
and it comes back almost to that to that
old sort of polish line you know for
your freedom and ours you know we are
right we're not
um
um
sending nato in we're not allowing
ukraine to nato that would be kind of
suicidal to everybody i suspect but we
are arming arming the ukrainians we are
assisting in any way possible and
everyone's shoulder shoulder to the
wheel you know and we we finally it's
almost like i think woke is almost woke
has almost been like um like an
autoimmune disorder it's like lupus you
know when you've got when there's
nothing else going on your body attacks
itself yes right we've suddenly found
out that there is an external enemy and
we've got to concentrate on that and
hopefully it means we can concentrate a
bit less on the naval gazing in the
process
there's also one country who we haven't
spoken about who are
i'm sure looking at this with a very
keen eye and it's china
what role do you think they're going to
be playing and what do you think they're
going to be taking out of this i think
they're watching very closely
you know because of course they have
their
claim to uh to taiwan um that's their
sort of uh piece of
uh iridenta in the world um
and they're gonna be watching very
closely as to the western reaction
and i think again i think they will be
uh
held back actually by that reaction by
the strength of that reaction because if
you look all the stuff we've said right
about the western world being divided
amongst itself you've got you know the
brexit thing you've got the woke stuff
going on
you know the western world in the last
sort of five six seven years has been
you know
kind of as divided as i can remember it
in many ways probably since the cold war
when we had those great
chasms in sort of opinion and so on
um
and yet in the last week
almost complete unanimity
except for the fringes you know you're
dying abbotts and and so on who still
want to come out and stop the war and
the rest of it and again the analogous
on the right which we talked about but i
think that they're fringe voices
real unanimity and i said that that um
that sense of this we will defend and i
think it's admirable and that that is a
strong message to china as well so i
think they they've got a really
careful watching brief on what's going
on and i think they will be their hands
will be stayed by what they've seen to
some extent i hope it's interesting
watching russian tv as i said over the
last week because that tells you what
the regime is thinking right because
it's that's where it's coming from
uh there's a tremendous amount of
cozying up to china going on tremendous
amount uh but the chinese have played a
very closed hand on this one they
haven't supported russia outwardly they
keep talking about how there needs to be
peace and whatever
uh so we wait and see as you know in the
chat we had a week ago i was perhaps a
bit doom and gloom about things and i've
been surprised as you have by the the
response from the west
and also the chinese don't seem to have
jumped on this as the opportunity to
think this is the time to go for the
jugular which is a relation i think i
think i think if the west had hesitated
yeah that i would have expected and
certainly germany would have yeah i
thought germany would be the break on
any sort of serious eu involvement had
that happened yes then i think you might
have seen some chinese action elsewhere
because they're just exploiting the
opportunity that's why i think that
they're staying their hand
uh
there's a bunch of questions have flown
in um cat uh says uh with the 10 aussie
dollars says what are your thoughts on
the cultural sanctions currently being
implemented by the west such as banning
russian artists and athletes
historically has this been useful um
it's tough on the individuals themselves
um
who in
some instances you know we don't know
but in some instances are you know
blameless
in all of that um so that that there's
going to be collateral damage of course
but then you look at something like the
um
the boycott in south africa that running
through the 1980s up to the end of
apartheid which by all accounts you know
that that cultural isolation sporting
isolation worked right
um
so it's got to be
i suppose part of the
of the toolkit of the west we have to i
think we do have to hit quite hard
and if that means as i said some
collateral damage along the way then
that's regrettable but it probably has
to be but i don't imagine you'd support
banning fiora dossiers if
see i i would argue that unless it
needed to trigger warnings yeah
i'll tell you what russian literature
from that period needs a lot of [ __ ]
awarding but
what i would say is i think it's very
important that sanctions are targeted at
people who are uh supporters yeah and
bettors and whatever the right words are
people who are allowing this to happen
by their support
rather than just random russian people
who happened yeah that that makes it
sound like a lynch mob which is yeah i
mean there was that example of um i was
at the munich um
conductor who was who
essentially refused to come down either
way refused to condemn it and he was
sacked which i i think is probably
pretty heavy-handed yes i agree i think
friends of the regime are legitimate
targets for me
having said that you know i mean i
understand the west's desire to do
everything we can and as i think we're
both encouraged all three of us are
encouraged by the response but also like
i sending oligarchs back to russia is
actually what putin's always wanted he
wants that money back in russia so i
don't know how much punishment there is
and of course just punishing like
russian people in the west most of them
are in the west because they don't like
the regime so you're sending putin's
critics back to russia to punish him
and that but that again and it goes
against everything that that you know
the western model should be and yes in
an ideal world you know whatever happens
with ukraine but in an ideal world
there's has been a sort of a growing
middle class in russia who
have contacts and they have
feelers out in the western world they
know what the west is like they don't
necessarily buy the propaganda
and you need to give them a workable
model for them to say this is what we
want russia to be right
we don't want to as you say throw the
baby out bathwater and start you know
arresting people in the street and you
know
breaking our own our own laws to
basically you know punish random
russians because that's not sending a
positive message so it has to be you
know legal and and sort of commensurate
you know so what do we do with a product
with a channel like russia today
yeah that's a good question i mean
that's that's one that which has been
banned has been banned now yeah of
course and and i think that's probably
fair enough
it's a it's a you know complete
propaganda mouthpiece
um i was asked to go on it years and
years ago and said absolutely absolutely
not and they never asked again
um
yeah i think that's probably okay that
that's that's because
we are in cold war too and i think we
have to
accept that shutting off your enemies
propaganda is probably a quite a good
idea
it's interesting
i'm i'm instinctively very hesitant to
approve of that um for the reasons that
you gave earlier actually which is
that's a very unwestern thing to do but
i think if we accept the thing that you
and i both have actually said
there's an argument to be made at least
i i still i think i would i would resist
that temptation but i think reasonable
people can disagree about that
yeah yeah
oh some maverick christian what a name
well done maverick christian is asked
the question uh why did practically
every expert get it wrong
on the russian invasion of ukraine
yeah and um not that i'd call myself an
expert but me too and i think it's that
question we addressed at the beginning
was that
um
we're kind of
thinking in terms of putin being a
rational actor and he and he is getting
he was getting everything he wanted
by saber-rattling and by by sort of
throttling
ukraine and getting all of that sort of
western attention which he wants he
wants to be reminded that russia was a
great power and a big player in the
world and all of that
um and it seems unthinkable that he
would want to
launch full-out all-out war
um
it still seems unthinkable i'm like like
like constantine said it's like you know
you almost wake up it's like a dream
that's mad
um
that said
uh there were enough
voices amongst the sort of intelligence
community and so on who'd seen
various briefings and
i listened retrospectively actually
earlier this week i listened back to a
podcast an american
intelligence community podcast
which had three or four commentators on
there and they all differed i mean they
all say oh no i don't think he's going
to invade because he's getting what he
wants that argument that i gave and this
predated the invasion
um and two of them said he wasn't gonna
invade and two of them said he was
so there were voices that were saying
you know the intelligence is such that
you know this is not a drill
so there were voices there that were
saying that um but as i said i think the
rest of the world just assumed that you
know he was effectively
like if you actually look at putin's
history former head of the kgb you look
at
you know the case of alexander
lipbanienko you look at the poisons in
salisbury
this isn't a man who values human life
very highly particularly if it's if it
means that he can eliminate them in
order to get what he wants but again
this is
i'm sorry to you know say this with you
there constantine but this is kind of
also
um
an element of the russian psyche 100 you
know i i don't want people to be under
any doubt about what you're saying yeah
it's a hundred percent true i mean
you've got to understand this is a
country that killed 20 million of its
own citizens only 70 years ago or 80
years ago whenever it was and you go to
it you go to i mean things always
surprises me in a way is you go to any
of the
um
red army's cemeteries but like there's
three in berlin right from the battle of
berlin in 45.
um
the biggest one in treptor park which is
is spectacular sort of monuments
gigantic but they're mass graves like
they're mass graves of 5 000 people each
in each of these mass graves right so
the idea of the individual
and they're not repatriated i mean the
way the americans repatriate their dead
from war
as a matter of routine
um
russians don't do that right not only do
they not do that they put them into mass
graves so that there are no names right
we don't know who they are which to a
western mind within all of its
individualism and all of that is kind of
it's completely anathema it's kind of
wow that's that's
that's punchy you know
that's just the way it works it's the
way it works in 45 it's the way it works
now and that comes direct from the
soviet lens doesn't it
where the individual is
um
the long hard winter yeah i think it's
it you know man is
the individual is kind of expendable
and there are there are greater um goals
to be had and we we get them by
moving together and if the individual
falls off falls off the side then so be
it it's it's that a classic kind of
you know um communitarian
mentality
that
the community is everything the
individuals enough there's another piece
to it as well which is russia is a
massive country and because of that
logistically it was very difficult to
govern
and what you therefore needed is very
strong central leadership to prevent the
regions from becoming you know mini
tardems in which the the local
uh uppity king
would would do whatever he wanted
and because of that yeah this is the
anecdote i always use to explain to try
and explain this to people is uh one of
the
huge names in russian history is of
course ivan the terrible
uh he's not called ivan the terrible in
russian
it's not an inaccurate translation this
is a man who killed his own son in a fit
of rage who is a kid tortured animals he
did all sorts of atrocious things
in russia psychopath textbook psychopath
in russian he's called ivan the fearsome
and revered
yeah stalin has a 50 stalin has a higher
approval rating in russia today than joe
biden has in america or boris johnson
has in this country
that's the mentality and nobody in the
west can understand this because you
can't you can't if you if you operate
under the western moral framework it's
impossible to understand people who
would bury 5000 soldiers who secured
victory in the deadliest war in the
history of humanity
in the mass grave
you can't imagine that yeah
a way out that's what i've been arguing
yeah
um
and that probably means i think you know
in an ideal world in an ideal world
uh
they carry on the negotiations which i
think have been rather kind of cynically
led particularly on the russian side so
far that's a ruse to um to buy time
reorganize whatever it is
um but anyway at the moment those
negotiations in an ideal world you might
see ukraine being able to fight them
effectively to stand still
or make the costs so great that
putin is ready to make some sort of deal
and i think the best they could probably
achieve
from the ukrainian perspective is
is a return to status quarantine
right so you can have
don exclusive you can have crimea but
ukraine is allowed to exist now whether
it can exist
with an independent sovereign government
is a quite open question but that's what
it should demand
right
um
i think anything else is kind of
you know requiring it to be in a sphere
of influence
pandering to russian paranoia is is is a
hollow hollow victory
so for the ukraine so um that's an ideal
scenario i think that's about as good as
it's going to get
um
the other side of the spectrum the
realistic side of the spectrum is i
think the destruction of ukraine
and occupation of ukraine which is going
to be bloody
um
and ukraine's
democratic ambitions its ambitions to
join the west
western world in general are going to be
put back by decades
[Music]
so it's
it's
very dark we're in a very dark place at
the moment
and this is why i say this is this is
cold war ii
um we can't afford i don't think the
west to
whatever happens in ukraine
when it's over
go back to some pretend normal
because that would not be acceptable and
it'll be a betrayal
of all of those brave ukrainians who
have fought like they have
with that ambition
of fighting for their sovereignty and
their freedom
and to decide their own future
if we then
carry on business as usual
vandal deutsche handle
there's a betrayal of them and that
shouldn't happen so you know we do need
to carry on that fight
do you think the west i mean we've all
been surprised in the last week by the
resolve of the west but do you think
if ukraine is overrun
you know russia annexes eastern and
central part or installs a public
government
um
do you think the west has the appetite
to maintain these sanctions in
perpetuity
i i hope so honestly i hope so
um
and as i say i don't i don't think we
can in all conscience go back to
business as usual and so normalization
because you you'd have you'd have an
effect you know regime like lukashenko
in belarus in ukraine i think that's
probably the most likely outcome
which is horrible to say
um
and to me that is that is a tragedy
for ukraine
and it's something that we
should
carry on you know carry the carry the
torch effectively for
the freedom of ukraine and certainly
bolster our defenses on that eastern
frontier you know poland has to make
um you know
realize that it's a it's a frontier
country now um which i i said that last
week and prior to the invasion
it already already has felt that way
with the
with belarus and with the uh the
manufactured migrant crisis of a few
months ago
um
but baltic states poland you know
there's all those nato members on the
eastern eastern
fringe of europe
we have to make sure that that is an
inviolable line
but no further no step further
but that means putting nato troops
there absolutely
absolutely isn't that going to be seen
as an antagonistic gesture yeah i think
we're past that no
i think we're way better
it's the
the british the british in the french
prevailed upon the polls in three days
before the german invasion they said do
not mobilize because it would be
antagonistic to germany yeah you know
we're past that yeah yeah
all right roger morehouse thank you so
much for joining us i'm gonna lift this
book again because it's it's really
brilliant the devil's alliance the other
stuff you've written is great as well
but this i think this gives a little bit
of a better understanding of what we're
dealing with i think it's very important
for people to read this book and
understand the history of that part of
the world and it's beautifully written
as well really easy read so i
recommended the devil's alliance by
roger moorhouse roger thank you so much
for joining us thank you for watching uh
guys just so you know there will be no
raw show tonight because i'm on question
time uh so uh check that out and boo at
home and throw whatever you want to
throw uh but we will see you tomorrow
with our raw show and the rest of the
week will be as normal so thanks for
joining us roger thank you and we'll see
you very soon take care and see you soon
guys
hey francis would you like to learn
another language no mike already know
foreign language is perfectly boy gary
who a
biblioteca
you can't go on holiday mate without
knowing where the swimming pool is the
bible tech is the library you idiot
exactly you can never be too far away
from knowledge and sexually frustrated
librarians
for those of you who do want to learn a
language and connect with another
culture or maybe just brush up in your
spanish for the next holiday babble is
the app for you babble's 15 minute
lessons make it the perfect way to learn
a new language on the go babble designs
their courses with practical real world
conversations in mind things you're
going to use in everyday life like
finding out where the bibliotheque is
babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts meaning real people
so you learn useful vocabulary and not
meaningless phrases like the ones
francis keeps uttering babel's teaching
method has been scientifically proven to
be effective across multiple studies
with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including spanish
french italians and the other ones babel
is available as an app or online and
your progress will be synced across all
devices babel is offering our listeners
six months free with the purchase of a
six-month subscription with our promo
code which is trigger go to babble.com
forward slash play and use promo code
trigger for an extra six months for free
we're even going to get francis on it
you might learn english
that's b a b b e l dot com forward slash
play promo code trigger i use babble and
look at me now yo
absolutely perfecto know what i mean
gary do you have a website or do you
plan to have a website well if you do
then easy dns are the company for you
easy dns is the perfect domain name
registrar provider and web host for you
they have a track record of standing up
for their clients whether it be council
culture d platform attacks or
overzealous government agencies he knows
a bit about that so will you in a second
easy dns of rock solid network
infrastructure
and incredible customer support they're
in your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off with the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and sense